Oscar's are this Sunday very exciting
the Oscars yeah one of the one of the
most nominated films this year is
Dunkirk I really like that movie it's
Astoria about British troops that were
rescued in battle at Dunkirk by civilian
boats a great moment in history now one
of the film's nominations is for Best
Original Score I was surprised by this
nomination because I found some of Hans
Zimmer's music a little distracting but
take a look at this scene
[Music]
what you see
[Music]
[Music]
one of this year's Best Picture nominees
is call me by your name now this is a
really sweet movie about a young man's
sexual awakening now here's what's
strange part a lot of people first heard
about this movie because of an
embarrassing story about one of the
film's leads army hammer this is true
apparently the studio had to digitally
obscure Army's genitals because they
were peeking out of the bottom of his
shorts in one scene that really happened
it got a lot of attention it's the
reason a bunch of people went and saw
the movie and then it turned out to be a
really good movie sorry I look to you
and even anyway people were talking
about that it was a weird story going
around Hollywood and anyway here's that
hatch we'll seen that they had to
digitally fix see if you can figure out
where they made the digital correction
it's subtle but see if you can see it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't see it I couldn't tell either
yeah good Jonathan
you